otro asesinato de un periodista
convulsión a mexico el cuerpo de la
presentadora michel pérez desaparecida
desde el 18 de febrero fue hallado en el
sur de la capital con ella son 6 los
comunicadores asesinados en lo que va de
2022 por lo que reporteros critican lo
que califican falta de acción del
gobierno de andrés manuel lópez obrador
el presidente mexicano respondió que su
gobierno trabaja por esclarecer los
delitos contra los periodistas
en todos los casos
se está
actuando no hay impunidad
no son crímenes de estado y es que las
críticas han llegado también desde eeuu
el secretario de estado- anthony blinken
se sumó al pedido del fin de la
impunidad el alto número de periodistas
asesinados en méxico este año y las
continuas amenazas que enfrentan son
preocupantes me uno a quienes piden
mayor responsabilidad y protección para
los periodistas mexicanos mi corazón
está con los seres queridos de aquellos
que dieron su vida por la verdad
según la ong reporteros sin fronteras
méxico es el país más peligroso para
ejercer la profesión
aproximadamente 145 periodistas son
muerto violentamente en el país desde el
año 2000 hasta el 2021 según la
organización de derechos humanos
artículo 19